that is so excited so yesterday I found
out about this contest where if you win
you can go to space have you've been
following my videos for a while then you
know that this is something that I've
always dreamed of doing and when I found
out about cicadas I seriously cried at
the thought of actually getting a chance
to go to space no idea crying I really
ever asked you guys to vote for me for
anything which in return I end up always
losing but this is something that I
really don't want to lose now before I
get into why I want to go to space I'm
gonna show you guys how to vote all you
have to do is go to bit without ly /i
day in space and log in Facebook and
click Justine ezarik easier cuz my last
name don't be alarmed if you guys go and
it says Justin he's Eric is a him I will
be at him I don't care what ask whatever
you want me to be out of be a man as
long as I can go to space and I started
becoming obsessed with the idea of
actually being able to go to space
around 2008 I got a chance to go to the
Mojave Desert and interview Richard
Branson when they launched their Virgin
Galactic white knight 2 which is a
consumer-based Space Shuttle we've got a
couple more years of hard work we need
in the middle of here the spaceship
which is under a shroud in there to be
added for only about 18 months away from
going off into space and taking other
people into space
if you have an extra $200,000 laying
around but I mean let's be real it's not
really that realistic so the same year I
actually got an email from Norton
AntiVirus saying that they were
sponsoring a bunch of blogger trips to
go into zero-gravity I freaked out
amazing I wanted to be an astronaut
since I was very very young so I guess
it's probably the closest I'm gonna get
I believe there's two parts to this
contest but she's kind of crazy because
I had no idea who was really enjoying
this and I logged in so the two other
top youtubers or in the lead Alexander
is but I'm gonna go to space because
Dalton there's a space training camp
that you have to go to well my friends
mr. smooth and mr. 7st
let me just tell you what I have seen
Roman puke and be very uncomfortable in
these zero-gravity situations and we
tell you what I was perfectly fine do
you know why because I was born to be an
astronaut even though my mother would
say differently
I have indexing her if she does not
approve of me going to space I'm sorry
mommy this is something that I have to
do I have to do this for
Space Exploration I think you guys all
under dance for voting for all of your
tweets you guys have been so supportive
and I seriously appreciate it more than
anything
the official hashtag is IJ and space and
the official link to vote is bit leave
/ij and space I've been preparing to
vote a space from the past couple of
years a solo space training camp would
go on bring it on
I have already been training since I
found out about this contest let me tell
you how many pushups I've been doing who
I haven't done any yet but I plan on
doing some push-ups because I feel like
if I'm strong it's probably not gonna
really matter in space so if they'll
stop doing push-ups because
weightlessness you don't really need to
be strong oh god I shouldn't need to
rethink my training process astronaut
food I love astronaut ice cream oh
freeze-dry anything and I was take it
with me and a little lunch box
I don't well I will get a lunch box I
will even pull on I'm going to take my
Furby of space tell me how do you feel
about going to space give me an honest
frickin answer you're worthless
we're not weightless right now I think I
broke him